amber alert is in effect for two young  boys missing out of utah and they may be  traveling through our area take a look  we got that emergency alert that all of  us received on our phones around 9 15  this morning eight-year-old manson  rowley and six-year-old arson mangum  were last seen wednesday you see their  photos right there they are described as  being white with blonde hair and blue  eyes and they were last seen with  derrick rowley you see him there in a  gold chevy silverado it's the car that  he was driving police say that all three  may be traveling from utah to washington  state we have more details on the alert  inside our app and of course on eight  news now dot com